GM unveiled its new Chevy Camaro at a
ceremony in Detroit this weekend the
goal is clear GM wants to overtake the
Ford Mustang our Matt Miller was there
as he always is when new cars are
unveiled you join us joins us with
highlights from his conversations you
talked to Mary Barra I want to get to
that in a second but when we talk Camaro
Mustang I wonder has nothing change in
the US car market in the last 50 years
is it still biggest engine lightest body
know a lot has changed in the US car
market in the last 50 years but for the
people that care about this sort of
muscle car segment obviously you want a
big powerful engine and you want to have
a fairly light body I mean muscle cars
aren't as light as as other sports cars
are obviously but no you know one of the
things that Mary was telling me this
this weekend is that the people who
started out on cruise and in this in
these lower dollar segments that are
used to now turbocharged four-cylinder
'he's they're willing to accept that in
a Camaro so they're offering that
they're offering a v6 it's pretty
powerful I got a chance to drive and
then of course they're offering the 6.2
liter v8 I like all of us here in
Manhattan getting a lot of cars without
question the most uncomfortable car I
get into Cadillac without without
question that's the millennium colors
while you're most uncomfortable cousin I
think you're doing pretty well if it had
a most uncomfortable doesn't fit that's
in the real first one I was killing
what's the panic level on cadillac if
their sales aren't that good well
they're selling their investing i should
say over 12 billion dollars into
cadillac so they're really doing what
they can to make that brand better there
is a little bit of panic I mean you saw
last week Neville is Del who used to run
coca-cola and just retired from GM's
board said they need to do more exact
than just investing 12 oh [ __ ] urgency
from Mary bar well the problem is
marketing you know I talked to Mary
mostly about the Camaro and as Brendan
pointed out the only goal of Camaro is
to beat Mustang listen what she had to
say we're really proud of what the
previous generation accomplished of
leading and again it was you know the
market telling us that and I think when
you look at every aspect of the vehicle
I yes I think we will and that's our
goal I should point out that was an
exclusive look at the
car I got to see it before anybody else
did and talked to Mary about it a little
bit she wanted to focus on just the
Camaro obviously there has been a lot to
talk about for GM over the last year
year and a half but she's pretty much
overcome that I mean they've spent the
three billion dollars they need to for
the ignition recall they're now making
two billion dollars a quarter in profit
so they're doing fairly well let's be
clear on this item McCauley at citigroup
is adamant gml pays for is Ford afraid
of GM right now they definitely are not
winning in segments like this for
example performance cars in the US GM
owns this market share twenty-eight
percent of the entire performance car
market in the US I asked mark Roy's the
executive vice president for products
why performance is important our
portfolio of technology is developed
around the track and these cars and
you'll see cars all the way from the
Volt all the way up and then the spark
and the bev and the spark bebb all the
way through the top of the line
Corvettes are going to have technology
that we develop in the portfolio to do
that racing proves it so it's very
important part of our DNA so he's
basically saying the technology that
they developed for these performance
cars goes through down to the crews the
spark the sonic and that's what helps
them out as a whole money you're like
like do they make money here like they
do on a pickup truck they don't make as
much money as they do on pickup sure
especially in Camaro because look this
is a thirty-five thousand dollar car how
much a thirty five thousand dollar car
talk about the SS with a 455 horsepower
engine so that costs a lot but they are
making bigger margins than you on cruise
still on the pickup trucks and on the
SUV's by the way they own the big SUV
market with eighty-five percent of that
market they're making ten thousand
dollars all right Matt Miller thank you
Matt Miller by the way is never not
testing a car that's easy coming up I
enjoy testing the products of the
companies I report on so I can see how
they're doing you know as far as their
design and production is going